Beauty it's what it means to you I  absolutely love being in control of what  people can and can't see me having that  power means I am liberated your women  are put into boxes I personally as a  nice don't like boxes I want to reflect  my own creativity drawer outside the  lines I think there's a shift in people  being unique I'm a garden girl born and  raised in London my face was black stuff  people prejudge me for the way I look  thinking that it was a choice when I  lost my hair my feminine is you became  really important to me I think it's  about doing it yourself and not trying  to conform to some standard of beauty  I'm both masculine and feminine at the  same time I don't think you have to  choose one femininity is just a word  it's whatever you think it is whatever  it means to you my beauty my room  [Music]